what is the compensation the proper
compensation for customer support reps
csrs and then how do you keep them in
the role
for a long period of time or is it like
sdr or sales development reps in that
it's a transient position are there
people who are lifers who want to be in
this are there people who are transient
how do you deal with that yeah for for
us specifically i
believe it's more of a life for a role
but they can actually move up within it
you can we've been working on building
better career paths so that they can
grow within the team the reason i think
that it's more of a lifetime role is
because i find the people it attracts um
these people that are really good at
customer service they love it
i just had a meeting with one of our
csms today and it's just very
interesting they're
the happiness of the customer you can
really feel is like what brings them joy
and that's how you found the right
person now if you find the wrong person
i do think you need to get them out of
that role quickly because
if they take things personally or if
that's one of the biggest red flags i've
seen it just
it's going to really crush a lot of
their energy and it's just not going to
be a good fit long term
uh now in terms of compensation and
rewarding them we
do a hybrid approach for resigns and
expansion
where they get some of the commissions
for when a customer does resign
afterward
so then it really does put your sales
and your customer success on the same
team
because they are splitting the
commission at the end of it which has
been really helpful for us
ah so using a customer support rep to
get
the expansion going from one or two
seats in a sas company to three or four
or
to renew a contract that is
a great moment because they've been
helping the customer they know
what they've been experiencing and maybe
it's a better person to ask
for that signature or that re-up
exactly we actually for that i was
talking a little bit about where's the
line between and who's responsible for
what
our line is actually when a customer's
uh
contract is ending with us it's the
customer success person's job
to follow up with them and to get that
call to renew if they haven't
automatically renewed and then the sales
person actually joins them but the
customer success runs the meeting
because they know the client the best
and then the sales person is just there
to help upsell
and get them to sign on the dotted line
at the end so that's how we work
have you considered just having the
customer support manager rep whatever
get them to sign or are they
uncomfortable asking for that signature
yeah so sometimes they will resign um
without needing a little extra meeting
or whatever they'll just ask for oh yeah
we're just renewing for the ones that
need a little bit more handholding or
the bigger contracts we definitely push
for a meeting because we know we can
expand it more
i just find that the salesperson has
like a different repertoire of skills
that they bring to the table in terms of
the upsell and that's why it's been
good we've tested different options but
at the end of the day the
sales people are very good at selling if
they are good at their job
so they're good at identifying
opportunities and for expanding the
contract
where that customer success person is
like that comforting friend and
warm blanket that makes them feel you
know comfortable to keep working with
you
nicole any thoughts you want to build on
there in terms of
the line between sales customer support
and who develops the better ongoing
relationship
yeah it's a good question and it's
something that we've really
wrestled with a lot as well and i think
it's an ongoing conversation for us
for us a big thing is customer usage so
we sell membership packages and so
if we don't have a certain amount of
hours used
in a month then that's a trigger for us
this there's some there's an issue
with customer success and so one thing
that we've been doing
is we have we give our sales team
commission off of not just that
subscription fee
or that monthly membership fee but
actually any overages
that the customer uses so they're really
incentivized
as well to make sure that not just
through the sales process but also
through the onboarding process
and then even further that they're
constantly
invested in the customer success and so
they're also getting on the phone when
customer usage falls below a certain
percent we have
monthly meetings where our entire team
is on and we understand
how our customers are using and what
what that customer usage
is like and every single person on our
team
is picking up the phone and making those
calls and reaching out to customers
it's got to be a morale killer if you
get the sale and then they don't use the
product conversely
it's got to be just an incredible morale
boost when they blow through their
credits and have to buy more have you
learned
things nicole from these customer
support moments
that have been productized and
somebody's got to come up with a
creative idea
of how to get more usage how does that
ideation
work or how has it worked and are there
any techniques for
coming up with new ideas to drum up and
increase utilization absolutely
so a big thing for us right now is
return to office
so this is happening across all
industries
and one thing that we've done is we've
created a campaign
for existing customers so they
understand
how other similar customers in their
industry are using us
to more effectively return their
employees to the office so that's one
thing that we
do a lot of where we look and i
mentioned this a little bit in the
presentation but we look
at similar customer profiles and then we
create campaigns around that for
existing customers
to help them understand not just how we
can help them
in how they originally signed up but to
give them ideas
outside the box for how they can use us
in different ways and what different
opportunities
are that so one it even jumps from
client to client you have a client who's
returning to the office
now you have an opportunity to take the
best practices learned there
and share them with folks either in an
email or a phone call
etc i wonder if you have questions for
each other having watched each other's
presentations
or was there an idea kristin you got
from nicole or nicole from kristen
that inspired you to think about your
business differently
yeah i had a few i thought that the
first one i loved your presentation i
had a lot of
different yeah i had a lot of different
i think
similarities even though i know our
businesses are different it's there's
always a lot of
applicable things one thing that i know
you were talking a lot about is the
wrong customer segment and going after
it and that's something we've been
working a lot on
is trying to to identify our different
customer segments and
although someone spends less money but
stays longer like who's more valuable
and then you said you were like burning
your ships what was like the turning
point for you to finally like realize it
was it like straight revenue numbers or
was it usage or what was like the actual
kpi that i guess
allowed you to make that decision to cut
off that cus those customers completely
yeah it's a great question because as i
said like at that point
70 of our revenue was still coming from
small businesses
but the usage was very low and the churn
was very high
and the our customer feedback was
very terrible and so when
we started seeing these customers that
we they were we were getting fantastic
feedback from them we weren't getting
the turnover
and we their usage was through the roof
they might sign up for a package of 10
hours
but in some cases one customer would use
a hundred hours
in a month and so we that was like the
aha moment
that this the revenues may be
not there yet but all the other signs
are pointing
towards success in this area and
it was a very difficult decision but
once we
did that and moved our momentum in that
area that's
when everything changed in our business
today many small business owners are
busier than ever
because they're focused on managing and
growing their business they can't always
spend the time
they wish they could on recruiting
that's why linkedin jobs has made it
easy to find and hire the best
candidates
for free here at launch hiring is
definitely a part of my strategy a
critical part of that process
is using linkedin jobs why because there
are 740 million professionals on
linkedin and you know what you get the
right person in the right position and
all of a sudden it makes coming to work
delightful
every problem seems like it's solved and
you feel invincible
conversely when you can't fill that
position you feel like your company is a
disaster
that's because you're only as good as
your team and it all starts on linkedin
jobs you can find the right person
for your role right now and your first
job posting is free
because linkedin loves this week in
startups and this week in startups and j
cal
love linkedin am i talking about myself
in the third person i guess i am so
here's how you get that free first job
posting linkedin.com
your startup linkedin.com your startup
y-o-u-r-s-t-a-r-t-u-p
you're starting linkedin.com says your
startup to get a free
job post it today terms and conditions
of course supply because they're giving
you something for
free thank you linkedin for making my
life so easy i found so many great
people on the service and i love all the
great features you have the news feed
god live groups all these great features
you keep adding them
and i keep using linkedin more and more
okay let's get back to this amazing
episode